absolute rest is an important factor in
treatment and every effort should be
made to prevent the seriously ill
patient from waking on himself eating
drinking changing positions and many
other ordinary activities which seem to
require but little exertion when one is
well may become severe strains on a
patient six of pneumonia the public
health nurse even if she can make only
one or two visits often can teach the
attendants better ways of caring for the
patient's the process of taking the
increased amount of fluid which the
doctor may order becomes exhausting when
the patient has to lift his head many
times a day to drink how much more
simple drinking becomes when a soda
straw or glass tube is used regular
cleansing of the mouth is important in
pneumonia as in any other disease
accompanied by fever the lips and tongue
become dry and uncomfortable a solution
of salt and baking soda is used as a
mouthwash
regular bowel movements and emptying of
the bladder are essential this is
particularly so if certain drugs are
prescribed sitting up on the bedpan is
very exhausting
a cold pan is most uncomfortable it can
be kept warm on a radiator or be worn by
rinsing with hot water
an enema may be honored for abdominal
distension the doctor may also request a
record of the amount of spirit taken in
and the approximate daily output a
urinal should be provided for a male
patient the team due to these necessary
bodily functions can be minimized if the
patient is kept in a reclining position
when using the bedpan or urine
let us show the bedpan technique using a
demonstration subject bending the knees
in this manner permits the most
efficient use of powerful muscles of the
side without danger of the feet slipping
where their hand well under the patient
the nurse helps her raise her hips as
the bedpan is slipped into place a
sponge bath or alcohol rub and changing
the bed linen ordinarily contribute to
the patient's ability to rest but can be
very tiring if he has to lift our turn
himself
note how the nurse is starting to turn
the patient on his side turning is an
essential step in giving a bass are
changing the bed when properly done it
requires little effort on the part of
the patient and is less difficult for
the attendant the patient is kept
covered as much as possible to prevent
killing rubbing the back with alcohol
cools the skin and relaxes the tired
muscles particular attention is given to
the shoulders hips and lower part of the
back we leave our patient again for a
demonstration of the turning technique
flexing the legs eliminates any pull on
them as the hips are turned where the
firm hold and a lifting movement the
hips are partially turned the legs are
adjusted to maintain this position
the shoulders are turned in like manner
the back is continuously supported the
hips are turned at right angles to the
bed and lifted slightly backward the
legs are comfortably adjusted the
shoulder turn is completely
an extra sheet which has been folded in
half is used to protect the bottom sheet
because it can be changed easily to
avoid lifting the patient's the chief is
treated close to him while he is lying
on his side
when the patient is turned on his back
the sheep may be pulled through easily
a nightgown if slipped down the back can
be put on more easily
pneumonia germs are contained in the
discharges from the nose and throat
the wife is instructed to burn the
newspaper bag which contains the soiled
paper hankie
several thicknesses of clean tissues are
placed within easy reach of the patient
immediately after use they are dropped
into a paper bag which is pinned on the
side of the bed
in leaving the nurse instructs the
patient that complete rest will help him
to get well quickly and that he must
take it easy and let his wife help him
in every way possible
the in-service mark our apron in the
sickroom and thorough washing of the
hands upon leaving it are emphasized as
a means of protecting other members of
the household against the infection
the nurse reveals her instructions and
leaves a pamphlet on pneumonia care with
specific points marked for reference a
plan for managing the household
throughout the day and night is worked
out so that the wife may take care of
the patient with the greatest
conservation of our own strength the
frequency of future nursing visits will
be determined by the condition of the
patient the ability of the wife to give
care and of course the urgency of other
demands upon the nurses time